night in and night out he showed up a
lot of you youngsters like to say well
that's so old school yeah showing up is
old school being on time is old school
and doing your job is old school dan
issa was definitely old school
[Music]
[Applause]
so let's talk about carl anthony town
the thing that i really admire about
towns is how he's persevered throughout
his short career in the nba but also how
his game has changed and expanded in the
nba came in as a post player now has
expanded his game out to the three-point
range towns can put it on the floor he
can pass it he can plug up the middle
block shots he can lead on a break and
then if you want to he can stretch way
out to the three-point line and knock
down the three that's what i love about
carl anthony towns and you may think
that watching a player do this is kind
of the first time that some of you young
people have seen it well let me take you
back to a guy by the name of dan issel
carl anthony towns is called the cat
where they call danis of the horse
there's the horse danny issel look at
this kissel
soars to the basket
with
swish
and this is done passing to isil and a
good two-pointer let me tell you about
the horse dan issa you want to talk
about a power forward stretch big what
made dan thistle so difficult to guard
is athleticism he had hops where he can
get to the basket he can put it on the
floor he had good shot fake go around
you dunk it then again the pure shooting
stroke that he had that's what made him
really difficult from the aba to the nba
he was a problem
[Music]
missile on the right side of english a
little set shot is good
[Applause]
playing against denver they play a
similar style to what the golden state
warriors play today it's a read and
react passing game type offense where
anyone can initiate the offense they set
screens and when you were talking about
garden kiki vandeway alex english dan
issel you're talking about a back line
that all three of them at any point in
time could get 30 to 40 points a night
you know i seen it live where i think
kiki got 50 and alex english got over 40
on us in one game uh it actually
happened to be the highest scoring game
ever in the nba issue
english vandaly definitely ranks up
there with some of the best scoring
backlines ever in the history of our
game
are you kidding me what a shot
skies
for his career only missed 24 games
night in and night out he showed up not
only did he show up but he always gave
his best performance and he always was a
crowd pleaser a lot of you youngsters
like to say well that's so old school
yeah showing up is old school being on
time is old school and doing your job is
old school dan issa was definitely old
school so watching towns kind of reminds
me of isso the perseverance of towns has
shown throughout his personal trials and
tribulations in the nba going through
the covet nightmare losing just close
people to him but still showing up every
night still being a part of the team not
using it as an excuse but using it as
motivation and inspiration not only for
himself but also to others i have great
respect for carl anthony towns and i'm
wishing him a lot of success throughout
the rest of his mba career
[Music]
[Applause]